avait ce côté effectivement très ancré
sur la vie sociale du quartier que j'ai
beaucoup aimé way
[Musique]
je
c'est un samedi soir on est sur le point
de faire un gros service on a même
devant nous un gros week end en fait
donc mes chambres froides sont pleines
et là on nous annonce qu'on va fermer le
soir à minuit pour remettre un contexte
en fait le restaurant avait ouvert cinq
mois avant donc c'était hyper frustrant
en fait ces annonces la et très
rapidement en fait moi je dis c'est pas
possible je peux pas fermer fin ya
tellement investissement personnel en
fait dans un dans un restaurant que je
pouvais juste pas baisser les bras comme
ça quoi
[Musique]
l'idée en fait elle est venue d'une
discussion que j'ai eue avec un mes
producteurs quand il ya eu ce coup
d'arrêt pour les restaurants lui c'était
aussi le coup d'arrêt par répercussion
de son activité puisque c'est quelqu'un
qui travaille quasiment uniquement avec
les restaurants je sentais vraiment la
peine danser dans ses propos à l'époque
souvenez-vous les marchés étaient fermés
donc en fait on a vu que les
supermarchés qui restait en fait faut
voir à paris je me suis dit ok si moi
j'ai envie d'avoir accès à des légumes
de qualité je suis sûrement pas la seule
du coup je me suis dit pourquoi pas être
un trait d'union en fait entre la
population parisienne qui a envie qui
ont envie de consommer ces légumes de
deschamps directement et en même temps
les maraîchers qui sont qui se retrouve
le bec dans l'eau
[Musique]
voilà on a eu un super retour des
clients parce qu'on en fait il avait
accès à mes produits sains mon garde
manger donc ça déjà ça leur c'était
quelque chose d'assez inédit pour eux et
auquel il était très réceptive les gens
venaient en même temps acheter les 40 et
en même temps preniez des drus c'est
tout bonnement d'un petit conseil
[Musique]
on avait un camion qui nous déposait de
la nourriture brut le matin lounes avez
toute la journée pour pour les cuisiner
et puis pour pour le transformer les
faire quelque chose de plutôt sympa et
l'après midi on avait un des courses est
qu'ils venaient qui a récupéré donc ce
qu'on avait cuisiné pendant la journée
pour le déposer aux hôpitaux
[Musique]
ça nous a permis de renforcer sur lien
avec le quartier ça m'a donné aussi
l'occasion de discuter plus avec les
gens parce que c'est vrai que même si en
cuisine
quand je suis en cuisine la plaine est
très ouverte et je prends souvent le
temps d'aller débarrasser une table
aller disputé à droite à gauche
c'est quand même pas la même chose non
plus fait d'avoir en face de soi
vraiment les gens comme ça au quotidien
quoi
[Musique]